tô lado de suazo que quem fala é o dado
que sejam muito bem vindos
ajude o mogi mirim vai ser muito
interessante porque porque comprei que
um novo brinquedo olha só o aluno aqui
dentro eu tenho uma base o que dispara
ar como vocês podem ver aqui na imagem
por aí
um homem super impressionado e um
brinquedo no eso quilos é mal aí sabe
como o inglês ashley no futebol era de
50 fitas não só vou traduzir dispara uma
boa arma mas que quer almoçar você sem
braço mas não é nada que não é só o
basicamente o que fazem disparar bolas
de armas que são muito pequenos momentos
aparece a imagem é o que eu vou fazer eu
vou montar aqui o brinquedo e vamos
tentar fazer um strip choques aqui na
casa vou tentar derrubar torres de copos
e vou tentar apagar as velas é muitas
vezes eu acho que eu nem sei como é que
o brasil acaba de vento podem só ela que
está muito porque nem é muito grande
pode também ajudar a construir a questão
é eu tinha uma muito parecida mas acabou
porque esta que está completamente nova
para lá u
mas antes disso antes de o brilho que o
nosso novo brinquedo já sabem só deixei
muito larga que neste vídeo sério quanto
mais leve que vocês deixarem mais os
meus vídeos são recomendados para vocês
estão em segundo e portanto mesmo já
sabendo que não foi inscrito no canal e
inscreva-se por partilha agora muito
vídeo novo aqui na colômbia porque
escrevo ou
grande por isso acho que isto o senhor
qualquer coisa que não o queijo acho que
pega num jingle quero ir agora para
colocar onda aqui embaixo nem eu não sei
montar esse louco é que como está tudo
certo
não é assim
em outra luta para fazer pontaria e na
boa fase e assumida ela foi mesmo contei
aqui agora é só voltar para o pastor
esta deve ser mais difícil final muito
coisa que montará que o brinquedo olha
só querer e estar 32 13 de maio
e eu ainda tenho outra surpresa mais pra
frente que no vídeo que eu vou usar é eu
usar uma coisa dentro destas nunca de
armas já mostra agora vou testar
derrubar alguns objetos por ela só então
fazer os trechos quando o cska tiro num
copo é curta distância tiro no copo é
longa distância é ter o dobro em curta
distância
confira o gol é o longa distância após a
proibição muito inspirador tiro tribo é
curta distância e triplo longa distância
[Música]
'como assim é muito divertido ser
diretor do copo
eis a tiro a 523 um pai ligou missão
impossível na cozinha vira uma piscina
[Música]
que o rio machado é e agora vou estar
aqui com velas e vou tentar apagar as
velas com o ar que sai da nossa juca por
latrocínio das vendas ou encontre um diz
que há pouco tempo eu só que eu tenho
dentro é uma chama pois mas eu achei uma
fornalha
como é que é possível nunca me esqueci
meu é muito bom ok vamos acender as
velas
[Música]
tiro revela em curta distância
outro tiro na vela é o dunga distância
[Música]
eu vou conseguir pagar o tributo e
novela é longa distância e fez belos de
uma vez eu fui tudo tentativa de apagar
todas as belas com um tiro a tiro um
amigo lucas tem aqui um comentário
pessoal eu posso puxar a antena e tem
que os botões o que acontece eu quero
ficar num desses botões
olha só 32 o pessoal está aqui é uma
máquina de fazer fumo e quando vocês
sabem se eu colocar fumar aqui dentro do
ar
nós vamos conseguir obter forma então é
isso que nós vamos ver vamos ver qual é
a forma que tem aqui dentro desta
brazuca
i e ii é muito fundo vai vir 321 bora lá
em casa sábado
eu não sei como é que vou aparecer aqui
mas de roubar eu vou mais passar por lá
pessoal só temos aqui nessa sala eo bpi
também está aqui do enem 21 mil
olha isso dá uma ambiência muito linda e
os deixa à vista que no chão dá pra
fazer uma festa ou lançado
a flip para lá três do estudo
o rugir muito agora face a face da costa
leite 321 vai calma de encher muita
fumaça agora muito mais
goooool do espaço entre minha roupa só
vou experimentar usar o fumo dentro da
minha camisola 31 vai embora que alguém
vai ter que quebrar essa lógica essa
ajuda
eu só ficou cheio de fumaça tem muito
fumo mesmo então eu fugi para que
provasse a travessia e é isso espero que
vocês tenham gostado aqui dois filhos
para quem está aqui do brinquedo também
ainda não confirmar qual é muita coisa
lá em cima não é só tá cheia cheia mas
vocês não têm noção na câmara eu acho
que não precisa tanto lá em cima está
completamente cheio de fumaça eis o que
o estado deixe muito aqui neste blog
pessoal é muito importante mesmo aqui
pro canal só assim o youtube vai
recomendar vídeos pra vocês então isso é
muito importante é isso fique bem essa é
a próxima cidade
[Música]